es scheint zu schön um wahr zu sein wird
die medizin in zukunft alles heilen
können jede krankheit jede verletzung
einfach alles diese rosige zukunft
könnte durch künstliche intelligenz ki
tatsächlich realität werden der mit
computern werden immer öfter wahre
wunder vollbracht das jüngste wird die
krebstherapie revolutionieren und dann
kommt auch noch google bzw alphabet mit
ins spiel mit der künstlichen
intelligenz dieb meint die offenbart
sich jetzt als maschine mit superkräften
klicks um science-fiction
wir berichten wir täglich über die
unglaublichsten entdeckungen und
fortschritte in der wissenschaft
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's immer mal wieder lese
ich in kommentaren schon wieder ein
rekord wieder bahn brechen sensationell
wahnsinn hammer und so weiter ich solle
doch mal mit den ganzen superlativen
aufhören ich fürchte dass es aber mehr
werden wir leben nämlich in einem
zeitalter wo die forschung und der
technologische fortschritt sich in immer
höherem tempo entwickeln und das ist
wirklich bahnbrechend unglaublich hammer
und abo zu muss ich auch mal bot
ausrufen superlative werden wohl in
zukunft zu unserem alltag gehören und
das ist zum einen extrem erfreulich und
zum anderen auch dringend nötig denn
ansonsten bekommen wir die riesigen
herausforderungen auf unserem planeten
einfach nicht bewältigt und dieser
fortschritt könnte tatsächlich ein tempo
annehmen bei dem es auf die
vorhergesagte technologische
singularität hinausläuft bei der uns die
intelligenz von computern bei weitem
überlegen ist eine gefahr aber auch eine
riesige chance und in einem bereich
kündigt sich diese entwicklung schon an
in der medizin
wir werden immer neue rekorde
aufgestellt und unmögliche dinge
geschafft ein solcher meilenstein wurde
jetzt wieder erreicht und der es absolut
bahn brechen und zeigt uns auf absolut
beeindruckende weise wohin die
entwicklung in der zukunft geht daniel
adriano silva von der university of
washington und sein team haben eine
körpereigene substanz für die
immuntherapie gegen krebs
weiterentwickelt und das ist wirklich
revolutionär denn die anführungszeichen
bei weiterentwickelt die kann man
eigentlich auch weglassen
es geht um interleukin 2 das eigentlich
ganz wunderbar gegen bestimmte
krebsarten eingesetzt werden
eigentlich denn in größeren mengen ist
interleukin 2 obwohl körpereigenen
giftig das forschungsteam hat aber etwas
spektakuläres gemacht sie haben den
stoff tatsächlich weiter entwickelt und
noch eine steigerung und das per
computer wirklich absolut unglaublich
sie haben mit einer software rosetta
heißt sie das protein immer wieder
variiert und verbessert und dann in der
realität nachgebaut so wurde interleukin
2 immer weiter verbessert und es
schließt sich so optimiert dass es kaum
noch aussah wie das original und zudem
weniger schädlich und dazu auch noch
stabiler war als das original bei mäusen
lassen sich damit bereits darm und
hautkrebs erfolgreich behandeln damit
werden zwei dinge offenbar erstens dna
sind daten mit denen kann man rechnen
und zweitens ein computer hat das jetzt
mit überragendem erfolg getan und jetzt
kommt noch ein dritter punkt und dafür
fällt mir jetzt einfach wirklich keine
superlative mehr ein
rosetta ist dabei noch sehr sehr schwach
es gibt bereits einen wettbewerber der
fast die zehnfache leistung bringt
rosetta ist nämlich eine software die
beim kasper 13 wettbewerb eingesetzt
wird hierbei geht es darum aus dna
sequenzen als ausgangspunkt die proteine
zu errechnen
die daraus entstehen wie viel der 40
proteine werden korrekt errechnet also
wie sehen sie nachher aus das ist in der
medizin entscheiden je nachdem wie sie
aussehen also wie sie konstruiert sind
können sie gutes und nützliches tun oder
im anderen fall auch schlimme
krankheiten wie alzheimer parken sind
oder bse rinderwahnsinn hervorrufen
bei bse sind es zum beispiel prionen
atypisch gefaltete proteine und falten
dass es genau das richtige bild für den
aufbau von proteinen es ist ein bisschen
wie origami nur dass es nicht um ein
paar dutzend faltungen geht sondern um
so viele faltungen die man brauchen
würde um ein origami tier in echt und
lebendig zu halten also eine nicht ganz
leichte aufgabe kein wunder also dass
der zweitplatzierte nur drei der 40
verlangten proteine korrekt gefaltet
hatte jetzt kommt es aber das team von
der alfabet tochter dieb meint hatte ja
bereits mit alpha gezeigt dass es
bahnbrechendes leisten kann
es ist der beste spieler auf der welt da
haben ja darüber berichtet für den fall
wettbewerb halten heißt er auf englisch
fold haben sie alpha fortentwickelt
und alpha faulheit achtung jetzt mal
wirklich festhalten 25 der 40 proteine
korrekt gefaltet mehr als die hälfte
fast die zehnfache menge des
zweitplatzierten das ist wirklich
wahnsinn und jetzt möchte ich wirklich
hier mal alle superlativen abliefern
bahnbrechend unglaublich hammer bot das
wird die medizin wirklich
revolutionieren dagegen ist sie am
anfang vorgestellt revolution nur noch
eine revolution ziehen das zeigt
wirklich unglaubliche perspektiven auf
wenn diese maschine in der forschung
eingesetzt wird dann werden solche
fortschritte alltäglich und die
menschheit wird einen riesenschritt in
der krebstherapie machen und in der
behandlung von allen möglichen
krankheiten das wird wirklich wirklich
hoch hochspannend genauso übrigens wie
dieses video hier klicken für wie
intelligent ist künstliche intelligenz
von byd links unbedingt abonnieren da
gibt es schon sehr sehr bald neue videos
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran